[Música]
escala en París Ahí va para la
Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y de France
24 hoy dedicado a la política francesa y
más concretamente al partido socialista
francés cuyo congreso se acerca está
previsto para finales de enero pero
parece que este partido histórico no
levanta cabeza desde la derrota de
Lionel 2002 con unos resultados
catastróficos en las últimas elecciones
presidenciales y diluidos ahora en la
asamblea nacional en una coalición de
izquierdas liderada por la Francia
insumisa y para aclararnos En qué está
el partido socialista francés tenemos en
nuestros estudios a la periodistas hit
de villenas git muchísimas gracias y
bienvenida Hola Gracias bueno es jefa
del servicio político del haft post ha
seguido las campañas políticas de Juan
solom de John link melonso y Manuel
Machu y del conjunto de los partidos de
izquierdas desde el 2011 y además
publicar un libro los siete pecados
capitales de la izquierda editado por la
editorial latex yo le quería preguntar
por qué haber escrito un libro sobre la
izquierda y si los pecados capitales son
exclusivos de la izquierda francesa no
podríamos decir lo mismo para la derecha
francesa Pero yo quise escribir sobre la
izquierda porque me parece muy
preocupante su situación política porque
hace tres elecciones presidenciales
desde 2002 que no pueden ir a la segunda
vuelta de la presidencial y que el
hombre nacional la extrema derecha
está en esa segunda vuelta Así que para
mí hay como una emergencia para esos
partidos para ganar si ha habido como en
los últimos 20 años una excepción no que
ha sido Juan solón Pero hay como ese ese
declive en este libro
bueno analiza todo esto a través de los
siete pecados capitales establecidos por
Santo Tomás de Aquino y explica los
errores No del partido socialista
francés a partir de lo que usted llama
un fracaso fundador cuando Leonel
schuspa se queda fuera de la segunda
vuelta en 2002 y pasa la extrema derecha
de
todo un shock junto al conservador Jack
sirak y para
ilustrar esto vamos a vamos a pasar una
secuencia
[Risas]
Bueno pues es una entrevista previa a
esa primera vuelta al periodista le
pregunta Josh Imagine por unos segundos
señor candidato que no está en esa
segunda vuelta por quién vota y suelta
una carcajada qué pecado capital comete
su spa o partido socialista en ese
momento para mí y en el libro y para la
prensa de la época también es la
soberbia el orgullo porque
la primera cosa de este pecado es cuando
no dudes Y entonces él es Primer
Ministro en esa época hay más o menos
ocho candidatos de la izquierda y no
piensa que pueda
ni la extrema derecha pueda ganar esa
vuelta y en realidad nadie lo pensaba en
esa época mientras que en 2020 22 En esa
dirección presidencial lo mismo pasó Así
que la izquierda fue eliminada y la
extrema derecha fue calificada y para mí
es interesante
esa periodo son dos 20 años para
analizar porque son iguales en unas como
si no hubieran aprendido nada no que el
voto se dispersan entre los diferentes
candidatos de izquierdas sin que lleguen
a aliarse No desde un principio para
presentar a un candidato único para mí
no quieren mirar la realidad no quieren
ver lo que está pasando y así que no no
había que divisarse así porque los
electores no no quieren votar ahora por
para ellos en su libro también hace
hincapié en un momento dado los
atentados de París del 2015
qué influencia tuvo la actitud del
partido socialista y del gobierno de
fonshua olón de ante estos atentados que
influencia ha podido tener en su declive
para mí la fecha de 2015 es fundamental
está fundamental en esa en mi análisis
porque lo podemos ver en las elecciones
y también en las encuestas de opinión
desde ese momento muy importante para el
país la
los electores no quieren más votar para
el partido socialista mientras que
quieren mucho más votar para la derecha
extrema derecha Así que para mí es en
esa época el presidente
manejó la situación el país no se
dividió y bueno la pasamos más o menos
correctamente en el momento pero lo que
había que hacer para mí es analizar las
causas de los atentados Y eso no lo
querían decían Sus consejos Manuel Bars
el Primer Ministro y muchos en el
partido socialista decían no tenemos que
explicar los atentados mientras que hay
mucho para explicar lo que pasa en los
suburbios franceses lo que pasa en las
escuelas los que se radicalizaron y no
lo hicieran y para mí ahora no están
creíbles para la gente en esos temas en
esos temas muy importante para el país
cree que la izquierda trai sus valores
en nombre de las minorías justamente
cuando me habla de los suburbios de las
escuelas no sé si ha traicionado pero
para mí ha olvidado
las categorías populares la gente que no
gana mucha plata
históricamente la izquierda debe
defender a ellos los obreros y todo
ahora podemos ver que no tienen éxito en
los campos por ejemplo o en los la gente
que vive cerca de las ciudades pero no
en el centro y es esos que pueden
podemos decir eran también los chalecos
amarillos no votan más para el partido
socialistas y el socialista Y eso es un
problema mayor para ellos así que tienen
que ir en esos
territorios de Francia y hablar de temas
que pueden interesarle les para
y ganar las elecciones al final o sea
hay una especie de pereza para mí eso es
la pereza total es que están en París en
los en la asamblea nacional y no van en
los territorios es como para mí los
partidos de izquierda pero otros también
están como desconectados de la
populación Y eso es muy gran problema
acá aún así hay una implantación local
bastante importante porque controlan
muchas alcaldías no en los socialistas
incluso la de París y regiones como en
el sur con cajón delga por ejemplo Pero
bueno eso para mí es como un algo que
tienen del pasado y las podrían perder
también crees que para mí es como La
indiferencia en política y las últimas
elecciones regionales que tuvieron en
70% de la población no fue a votar Así
que no podemos decir que el partido
socialista tiene seis regiones pero
nadie votó para ellos un porcentaje uno
coma 75% en las últimas elecciones
presidenciales con anídalgo a la cabeza
Cuál fue el pecado de anídalo para mí es
el pecado original que es la mantierra
porque
en Hidalgo que quien es la
de París en 2020 dijo a sus a los
parisinos no voy a presentarme a la
presidencial y dos años un año y medio
más tarde va a la presidencial y para mí
eso no se hace
en nuestra época no se hacen mentir a
las a los electores
vamos a hablar de la ira y no tanto del
partido socialista sino de Gian melonso
por ejemplo que gritaba la República soy
yo en la puerta de los locales de la
Francia y sumisa de su partido porque la
policía estaba llevando a cabo un
registro no
sin embargo las últimas elecciones
presidenciales melonso bueno se ha
erigido como el líder de la izquierda
francesa no le ha pasado factura a este
pecado a melonson no para mí menos son
no está en la pareja Porque trabajo y su
movimiento trabajo un montón sobre el
programa la ecología
muchas cosas es muy muy rico el programa
de Sonic y también sobre
las redes sociales y
sus
meetings estaban muy interesantes para
la gente muy nuevos y todo pero en la
era para mí es su problema porque
la secuencia que que dijiste es para mí
como el
porque muestro al país su irá y para mí
si no puso a la segunda vuelta es porque
la gente no como tiene miedo tal vez de
él se dice Por qué grita así a la
policía y a que sí que le pasó factura
le faltó muy poquito eh Le faltó un
poquito para para llegar a segunda
vuelta y en qué categoría de pecado
capital pondríamos la confianza que le
tuvo olong a macul que era suministro y
La puñalada que le da Después no y
porque se presenta y crea su propio
movimiento y se presenta sobre la
selección la ingenuidad no está no es un
pecado pero no sé cómo decir para mí hay
como una
traición porque dijo que quería estar
con las categorías populares y su
enemigo fue la finanza Pero al final
hizo una política muy liberal desde el
punto de vista económico y
Majo también tuvo éxito porque como es
como nació sobre las ruinas del partido
socialista y de la derecha republicana
Así que él tuvo como un
sentido político no sé cómo decir y una
intuición una intuición sí que esos
partidos estaban como ya viejos y podía
hacer algo nuevo ahora no sé si la gente
acá no está tal vez
pero
pasó hablando su política estaba tan
distinta de lo que dijo durante su
campaña que la gente ya no confió y
vamos a terminar con una pregunta
brevemente el congreso del partido
socialista está previsto a finales de
enero
Cómo ve este congreso podrá Renacer de
sus cenizas o el partido socialista
francés está muerto
es difícil porque los hay muchos
partidos políticas acá en Francia muy
pequeños y no no se mueren en realidad
pero la situación es muy complicada para
él pero tiene una historia muy
importante y para mí no no se va a morir
Pero hay que cambiar muchas cosas y
trabajar tal vez no dejando la pereza
pues muchísimas gracias de Belén y le
deseamos mucho éxito Con este libro los
siete pecados capitales de la izquierda
Muchas gracias y gracias a ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir también por internet en rf
y mundo.com y en France 24.com Hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]